Gundrota:
about HTML 5 standards,
about evolution.
But in reality,
I'm not sure
we would've had this luxury
had it not been for Mozilla's
and the community's
phenomenal work
over ten years.
There was a time
when people wondered,
uh, if the--that the odds
were against you guys
with, uh, competitors
that had the benefit
of preinstallation.
But you guys really proved--
you proved--
that you could build a community
of hundreds of millions
of loyal consumers
who chose Firefox
and you could build
a better web.
So for all that you did,
for what you're doing now,
and for what you will do,
thank you.
Sullivan: Thanks.
Thanks, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you.
Sullivan: Well,
I want to thank Vic
for that introduction.
Um, not for myself,
but on behalf of the whole
Mozilla community
around the world
that's made that possible.
Um, it's an amazing,
vibrant, crazy organization
that it's fun
to be a part of.
Um, I want to do three things
today, um, real briefly.
I want to explain
why Mozilla's here at I/O.
I want to talk
about what's coming
in Firefox for developers,
and I want to give you
a brief demo
of geolocation support
in the browser.
So...
browser competition
is heating up again.
That's--that's no secret
to anybody here.
Um, and we think
this is very important.
As users live more and more
of their lives online,
it's very important
that we continue
to improve the user experience,
to make the browser faster,
and to protect user security
and privacy online.
And we see what happens
when there isn't any competition
in the marketplace.
Things stagnate.
There aren't new features.
The web does not get better.
Now, since we entered the market
with Firefox
and other browsers
have followed--
these modern browsers
that we're talking about today--
that's improved
the user experience.
So it's very important
to have that vibrant competition
in the marketplace.
And we're glad
that these other--
other folks
are producing browsers.
Now, it's also important to note
that each of our organizations
have very different missions
and motivations
for why we work
on web browsers.
But today,
we put all that aside
to focus on what we share
in common.
So we share, I think,
three important things
in common.
One, we believe strongly
that the web
is the development platform
for our time.
More than any single
operating system,
the web is going to drive
the innovation
and the new services that are
going to do amazing things
for people all around
the world.
We also share a belief
that we need to keep bringing
new capabilities
to you as developers
so you can create
these things.
And that means
that we need to move quickly.
But also we need to make sure
that we don't fragment the web.
There will be
no worse outcome
than through
this renewed competition
to have a fragmentation
of the web platform.
You should be able to focus
on--on building your house
and not worrying
about the cross-browser
plumbing.
So we need
to work together
to--to keep that standards
held together.
And that's a challenge.
And it's--it's the web.
So it's messy, right?
So we don't always agree
on what the perfect API is
to expose a new piece
of functionality.
We don't even always agree
on the process
to run some experiments
and then decide
which the best API
should be.
But I strongly believe
that a-a very, very good API
for something
that's in five browsers
is better than a perfect API
that's in no browsers
or one browser.
So we need to work hard
together with Google
and the other browser vendors
to hold that center.
And that's very important.
I want to talk a little bit
about what's coming
in Firefox 3.5
for developers.
Now Firefox 3.0
is the most successful browser
that we've ever built.
Um, we have about 300 million
users worldwide.
We just recently had
our one billionth
add-on download.
Um, so Firefox 3 has been
phenomenally successful.
But--but we believe
Firefox 3.5 is better.
We believe it's much better.
Uh, JavaScript performance,
which is
the underlying piece
that dr--that--that enables
all of this innovation
in these apps that we're--
that we're working hard
to build--
JavaScript performance
is three times faster
in 3.5
than it was in 3.0.
And ten times faster
than it was in 2.0.
So we've been working very hard
to increase the speed
of JavaScript execution.
Um, you heard a little bit
about how canvas works
and how video works.
And what I think
is important here
is getting things
like video
out of, uh,
out of plug-in prison
so that we can script them.
And when you combine things
like video and canvas
as--as Vic demo'ed,
you start to see the power
of being able to use things
through--through web APIs
and be able
to manipulate them
and mash them up
in new ways.
And that's really
a common theme
for some of this
new functionality
is it's the web.
You should be able
to touch anything,
hack anything,
and mash up anything.
Um, we're adding support
for geolocation.
And I'll talk about that more
in a minute.
We're also--we also have support
for offline storage
so that you can begin
to write apps that work better
when they're disconnected.
That's--that's very important
for mobile situations
and--and other use cases.
And we're also adding support
for Web Workers
so that you can write scripts
that run pretty intensively
without hosing your browser,
a very important feature.
And all this stuff is--
is, um, you can--
you can look at the link
up there and go there
and it'll take you
to a description
of how to use
these new APIs
and exactly what the level
of support is in Firefox 3.5.
Um, I want to talk
a little bit now
about geolocation support
in the browser.
So in Firefox 3.5,
there's support
for, um, the geolocation API.
And I'm going to give you a demo
of one of the apps,
um, that's going
to use this.
So be believe
that there are use cases
in--in many, many,
um, spheres
for geolocation support.
Um, we--we think it's going
to change how maps,
local search, directions,
all sorts of social networking--
anywhere where you want
to tag something
with your location,
we believe it's going
to change the nature
of how all
of those applications work.
One particular application
that's going to take advantage
of Firefox's support
for geolocation is Google Maps.
So Google Maps, shortly,
will be adding a new button
to the user interface
called "my location."
And if I click this button,
I get a prompt.
And I get request for--
if I would like to share
my location
with that web site.
I'm going to go ahead
and click share--
I'm going to come back
to this
'cause I want to talk
about this a little bit.
But I'm going to go ahead
and share my location.
Couldn't be determined.
Let's try that again.
Okay.
[applause]
Murphy's Law of demos.
Um, so--so I wanted to explain
what's happened there.
So, um, what happened
when I clicked that button
was the browser gathered up
the signal strengths
of all the nearby
Wi-Fi hotspots
and transformed that
into a latitude and longitude.
If it was a cell phone,
I could've used Wi-Fi
or I could've used
cell tower IDs
and the signal strength
of those that are nearby.
Um, I could even use GPS
if it's local to--to the device.
So there's a number of ways
a back-end provider,
uh, can enable
that functionality.
And because it's Firefox,
user choice is important.
So users will be able
to download
all sorts of add-ons
that are going to provide
that back-end location
functionality.
And web developers
can enable their applications
with just a couple lines
of JavaScript code.
It's dead simple to use
the API.
I want to come back to one thing
real briefly though,
which is--which is how a user
opts in.
I think this is very important
for features like this
that begin to blend services
with client-side functionality.
Now, when I click the button,
I get this mode list info bar.
Now, don't try
to write down the URL.
It's not going to work.
It's behind
some Google firewall.
Uh, don't try this
at home yet.
Um, so--but I get a--
I get information
about what domain name
is requesting my location.
I can click "learn more"
if I want to understand
how the service works
and how the privacy
policies work.
And if I just ignore this,
nothing happens.
If I close it,
If I hit don't share--
and I can remember
that not sharing
so that I don't get prompted
in the future--
any of those things
and my location
is never accessed
by the browser.
It's only if I explicitly
opt in.
And that has to happen
on a per hostname basis
for this to work.
So we're trying to err
on the side
of--of the user
being in control.
Even though it might include
an extra click here and there,
we think it's important
to err on that side.
So, um, that's it
for the demo.
We look forward to see
the--the great things
you're going to do
with geolocation
and with all
of these features.
So thanks, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you.
Thank you.
[applause]
Yeah, we love those guys
and can't wait to see
what they're going
to do next.
Uh, geolocation
broadly available
in modern browsers.
Uh, before we move on,
I should show you
one more geolocation demo.
Uh, Jay mentioned the importance
of using geolocation
in mobile scenarios.
We've got exactly one
of those demos to show you.
What you're looking at now
is Latitude.
Latitude is an application
Google released
several months ago
for phones like the BlackBerry,
or Windows Mobile
or Nokia phones.
What you're seeing
for the first time
is Latitude on the iPhone.
And there's even one more
surprise.
It's Latitude on the iPhone
in the browser.
And the reason
this is possible
is because
in the next generation
of Apple's
operating system,
they too have implemented
the W3C geolocation API.
So we're able to build apps
that were formerly impossible,
now possible right on the web,
uh, uh, on the platform.
You--you'll see this app
shortly after Apple releases,
uh, OS 3.0.
Okay, let's go back
to slides.
And by the way,
that's another evidence
of Google making the bet
on HTML 5
and really try to build
those flagship apps
so we can move
the web forward.
Now let's move on and talk
about App Cache and Database.